merci de répondre à nos questions ce
matin sur rtl france officialisation du
retrait donc des troupes françaises du
mali en fin d'opération barkan emmanuel
macron a récusé tout échec sur place en
afrique le sentiment c'est quoi échec ou
succès parce qu'on a le sentiment que la
france et est poussé vers la sortie et
non
un succès hamon à lui je crois que nous
ne sera pas en donner le choix sera très
difficile puisque nous savons
aujourd'hui de problèmes
avec deux clubs a lancé aujourd'hui la
situation est telle que les deux parties
rené conscience
et mis lé nom me sellini donc un intérêt
pour la france mais aussi les délais
pour aujourd'hui c'est déjà aux mains la
population aujourd'hui donc des primes
avantages puisque justement née de
l'association où j'ai utilisé ces termes
des traités dans l'action avec une
certaine acuité s'est endormi il faut
ici est de voir
sous différentes vagues
voyage provient de différentes tailles
nous sommes aujourd'hui donc éliminés ou
abonnés par des tags questionnement de
question donc que tu nous écrit à
quelques cents à savoir le pourquoi et
le comment des choses et quel sera
l'avenir
comme tout le monde à ce qu'on dit et
que je vais très français c'était
réellement
ça sera très bien
contre le terrorisme qu'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant
les télomères
il faut laisser dans l'histoire il faut
bien essayer de voir le futur
économiquement donc ces deux pays la
france et neuf alliés il se peut la
population aujourd'hui c'est là qu'ils
comprennent pas c'est vrai que la junte
aujourd'hui
je ratisse puisqu'il ne voyais comme ça
mais
ces gens qui sont
avant la vie je crois que mille étangs
et raison garder il s'agit d'éveiller le
monde
c'est pas la mire façon à mon avis de
faire des choses qu'il faut
aujourd'hui si l'armée française cette
base là c'est un problème
l'armée a aussi la population est en
prières aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire
à cette population de notre confiance
est
ce que il à ce sujet de communication et
squillaci j'ai donc d'explication
rationnelle au niveau de la population
des jeunes ont bien au niveau
des responsables qui soit là aujourd'hui
être selon vous l'avenir du mali
maintenant qu'il y à ce retrait quel
avenir pour le mali pour les personnes
sur place
mais tout à l'abonné ont des sachets
disco gentil nous savons très bien que
s'ils y avoir une négociation avec media
liste vous pouvoir régler le problème ça
sera le cas
merci booba d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste politique spécialiste de
l'afrique